hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within now
oh no I'm done with that I need to get
up get up get up please
up please kitty cat Adam on top go go go
you're adorable but I don't have time
for you there's kind of demons
everywhere
I'm guessing this lady is a bit of a cat
lady and that's her little piece of
memory that keeps her grounded whereas
the detective was crazy and I'm pretty
sure that nurse was his dead wife which
was fine okay so maybe I might be able
to meet up with Jojo and whatever is
Castellano it's just like it just
flashed back to me I just remembered
cost Castellano Costin ello I think it
was Castellano detective Castellano
detective captain Castellano yeah but
something here isn't there secret
secrets never come oh here we go
right here I knew it couldn't be that
simple okay there's gotta be like uh
it's got to be like a hint or a pattern
here that I can read off of to open this
up what is that stop mocking me come out
and show yourself or don't either one's
preferable with me okay so there's got
to be something else around here that
can give me an inkling as to what that
combination will be cuz otherwise I'm
just gonna have to brute-force it in
that could take a stop making weird
noises geez uh I got it
okay god I got I got it just had to redo
it in my head a few times No
got it thank you man but I still miss
note number two
damnit God God a and I have no idea
where I lost it so I don't even know if
I can backtrack and go get it but I mean
if you want to see like the super
secrets of this game I'm sure there's
other videos that could show you exactly
or you can play the game for you
no come back no off we don't only turned
around in the first game all right but
at least I'm following the trail of
blood down here for hope stiletto ladies
down patients emerging from the stem are
becoming more erratic the pathologies
seem to be amplified by the experience
now even worse patients now seem to
experience each other's psychological
trauma it's as if the users deepest
fears linger within the encephalon of
the system even after the session is
over the most concerning thing are their
most recent statements every single
patient claims does he eluded figure
slowly approaching them could be him his
consciousness existing as a ghost in the
system my curiosity has never been
piqued like this I want to know I want
to see what they see but it's too risky
for now yes it's absolutely too risky
why would you do that why would you do
that I almost forgot that something
horrible happened here oh I bet this
Oh aah I wasn't ready for that one I
wasn't expecting anything at all yeah
big dingus screw you oh well glad we're
off to a good start
thank you I don't want that okay what
else any of the secrets that I missing
anyone else want to pop out at me just
give me a little warning before you do
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha come on with the
hold there yeah okay so now I can go up
the same elevator that Castellano and
Jojo went up to and maybe I can meet up
with Jojo but I know that Jojo isn't
faring too well Frankie
an error has occurred okay I would have
rather yoke twice oh oh oh you didn't
see nothing 20% oh good
Oh where's the Freak am I going oh I
can't see where I'm going Oh oh crap is
it's worse to hide behind because then I
really can't see fuzzy-wuzzy there you
laughing before oh god oh god oh no oh
oh oh no oh god no oh just please oh
yeah thank you
power restoration thanks
good
oh you're so scary but dude I'm not
Lesley oh god I'm gonna oh god I'm in
the corner oh god please
I was right there oh I thought I saw the
reason I went to the handprint is
because the handprint was green I
thought that meant that I could go at
that point it was green and I don't know
why you're looking for Leslie that's my
job
you leave my job to me when I die why
did I do that
oh why did that happen what did they
happen it was on the wall oh god don't
shut up lady I really don't want to hear
right now
you know I'm gonna do over here we're
here yes you that beautiful things is
the thing do the thing yes do the thing
Oh
obey my whim okay oh it's to the rooibos
clean is appreciated yeah place is a fun
place because of your support yeah
you're welcome for me not getting my
blood all over your floor well is
stressful and awesome so that was so
cool so cool why is this big and glowing
if I wasn't supposed to come over here
don't they know how game mechanics work
gamers are attracted to pretty lights oh
that's a that's prettier light okay this
light was prettier I admit I didn't see
this light first I didn't know you
better not be back here go bang ease I'm
gonna call that creature leggy McGee
good old legs okay where are you oh hey
come back Joe Joe Joe Joe okay
come back no no no no look at me look me
hello hello hello hi okay okay
make it convincing Oh detectives I'm
here I'm staying uh Sebastian Joseph
Bastian does toss the lungs
Moebius so they sent you to take the boy
back and you trust them don't kid
yourself
you're just as expendable as your
partners are
as I was after all I did for them
we'll see how loyal you are when you
know the truth alrighty then
thank you you're right great Oh baby I
don't know oh I miss Jojo so my wish to
remain in the dark
probably about information that will
undoubtedly disturb you
let's go with yes I'm gonna go with
whole lot yes Oh
chapter one done knows it autos awesome
wow I'm so cool
moving right along keep it going baby
Oh guys so cool man that hiding sequence
was just so stressful it was great is
Jojo here Jojo I know Jojo no Joe no Joe
Joseph Jolson Jojo [ __ ] where did he go
I don't know good question
crossing paths he'll just have to fend
for himself
yeah how does just one track fine lovely
uh
man Castellanos had a better luck
finding Leslie than you oh right here
there it is baby
I don't know why that was like that the
way that it was but okay whatever
Oh Oh little piggy no no little people
are you picking one no okay cool where
am I now why am I in the sewers of all
places then again there was a whole lot
of wandering through the sewers and his
name was Ruby Victoria okay but now he's
Rubik inside itself understand Oh Reuben
was brilliant
designing the entire system by himself
but we conflicted over our intentions
Reuben has been dealt with the
consequences of trusting the wrong
people
okay he knows I'm here
he sure does you're not very well hidden
from him Oh No Axew sick Leslie No
Oh for some reason I thought it was a
clicker it might be a clue but I have a
weapon now oh that's right it's only a
one use thing that's good that's good
that's good
keep the weapons away but I got a ticker
the sky maybe maybe I don't I'm gonna
save it I'm gonna save it now if you
didn't see anything okay yeah I mean if
I don't need to use it then maybe I
could use it in the future where I might
really need it okay they were gonna give
me more anyway so I was actually alright
okay cool
I've got a little present for you let me
ask you a question huh
you ready to celebrate Xmas oh crap this
is supposed to be a sneak kill no
killing I was supposed to do that to you
okay I'm gonna can I can I go I cannot
okay I where I'm not I'm not new good
I'm not do good this went bad
muy Malo oh well I'm dead now
I forgot that I needed to sneak up
behind them this I was gonna stab him
right in the face I was thinking like
weapon kill kill kill but I can't do
that
cuz it's not what I'm supposed to be on
back here come on what is that
Oh
hoppip I'm so stupid ah why can't I do
this
he looks fun and now he's gonna look
good right I did it I did the thing
everyone is proud of me ha ha ha ha ha
god I cannot believe how stupidly I was
there you heard me I was stupidly
I remember it Oh what what how did he do
that he just immediately turns around to
be honest this is actually surprisingly
difficult to get right
don't turn around what did I just say oh
come on I just hit the one box Oh God
Wow
oh my goodness oh my goodness you all
all you guys saw wasn't a montage of
stupidity I cannot fathom how I couldn't
do that like I don't understand what was
wrong with my brain that
- so incredibly do everything wrong
there that took me ten minutes it should
have taken me one oh it was AI was
unbelievable I've never been that
terrible before I've never been that
incredibly bad at anything in my life I
was incapable of doing good there okay
now that we've moved past that Oh
hopefully I'll never have to do that
again hi okay bye
so why I still hear you
oh yeah jump down without like looking
or anything that's it this okay so
you're a looking for Leslie but why are
you looking for Leslie oh okay oh good
oh good I like this yeah huh what oh
crap it's never a good sign when the
water starts to boil around the cabin
thank you
thank you thanks for doing that I uh I'm
stuck
oh not an exploding
yep mads an explorer me
why get a gun I really hope it's limited
use oh I know what I need to do come on
come on come on come on
okay limited use everything use come out
then you Kabam what I shot you Oh
BAM so I can only shoot him one there
take a moment to reload I don't know how
many bullets I have I'm hoping unlimited
hello oh no you don't there you go
there we go what no don't reload just in
case just in case just in case
hey how's it go what I'm not good with
consoles come on come on woah you were a
little too close for comfort
no thank you Wow okay there we go hoo
boy who Nellie
for Nellie I'm you some mouse and
keyboard I am not used to I see you over
there no again with the know a whole lot
of nope you back there no reload reload
what there we go come on you okay load
oh hey oh hello I remember you you're
from the beginning of the game picking
the first game anyway
yeah combo oh hi what are you doing I
got your on the face [ __ ] yeah oh you
better run oh I got a gun now
oh I now I'm all out of bullets right
now I'm all out of bullets that's how
you do it that's how you bring combat it
may get stressful like like the moments
in dead space when you're really hanging
in your descent shooting or like in the
original desk place when the worn like
grabbed and pulled yeah that was really
cool because it was so stressful and
like oh man the consequences for failing
were so high oh man
you know after I did my playthrough of
dead space way back when I went through
and I played the game again on the
hardest difficulty just to get just to
experience all thinkin it was really
hard do so fun about the energy
completely experiment new building it in
a way you know what to do but I I don't
I don't make it very clear do like ah
this motion do I do one of those oh can
you get it oh look at you
that better not be brain I hope it's
this healthy spam why are your eyes so
red and what is that okay
whatever time for assets at halo kitty
kitty oh you love you you little kitty
who are you pretty kitty
okay alright so that's all for this part
here thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the annotation for
more videos and if you haven't already
check out the evil within an alien
isolation they were both great play
throughs hope you all are enjoying this
I hope this is long enough because I
just remembered I needed to cut out a
lot for the part where I failed so if
this is slightly shorter just knew that
I played longer and failed longer thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you
in the next video oh yeah II what I'm
doing this is every [ __ ] does that
stand for the penis [ __ ] does that stand
for these prongs are fresh